welcome to Sky News breakfast it's good
to have you with us Boris Johnson is
insisting that he will be Vindicated by
a report into partygate despite MPS
investigating the scandals saying he may
have misled Parliament several times the
Privileges committee says preliminary
evidence including text messages and
photos strongly suggests that covered
rule breaches could have been obvious to
the former prime minister
he's due to give evidence to the
committee later this month it comes as
the Daily Telegraph has published more
leaked WhatsApp messages sent during the
pandemic about the former Health
secretary Matt Hancock we'll have more
on that in just a minute but first this
report from our Deputy political editor
Sam coats does Boris Johnson tell the
truth
Gardens was followed completely during
number 10. denial after Denial in the
strongest possible terms I'm second
myself and Furious about that I've been
repeatedly assured that the rules
these words were false but did he know
that whatever happened the guidance was
followed and the rules were followed at
all times
those questions are what a committee of
MPS is trying to answer did Boris
Johnson knowingly mislead Parliament
over covid rule breaking in number 10
the first release of their evidence is
not pretty for the former prime minister
there is evidence that the House of
Commons may have been misled a culture
of drinking in the workplace in some
parts of number 10 continued after covid
restrictions began Mr Johnson failed to
tell the house about his own knowledge
of the Gatherings that is because there
is evidence that he attended them
breaches of guidance would have been
obvious to Mr Johnson at the time he was
at the Gatherings
yet still Mr Johnson claims he's
innocent there's no evidence to show
that I must have known I must have
believed that illegal events were taking
place is because I didn't and I thought
we were fighting covid to the best of
our ability in very difficult
circumstances in number 10 in the
cabinet office uh night and day but new
photos paint a somewhat different
picture Boris Johnson at events
surrounded by people and alcohol the MPS
investigating him say he must have known
this was breaking the rules those around
Boris Johnson in number 10 were clearly
worried about what was going on in April
2021 so that's before the stories about
what had happened emerged One Number 10
official wrote they were worried about
leaks of the PM having a p star star up
and to be fair I don't think it's
unwarranted
for those who lost loved ones in the
pandemic the anger is personal Lynn's
husband Gareth died from covid in March
2021. he is the leader of the country
who should be setting an example to us
and I don't believe him I think he knows
he's at fault and he's trying to cover
it up for the next two and a half weeks
we'll be picking over the entrails of
partygate once more what did Boris
Johnson know and when could this be good
news for Rishi sunak and an opportunity
to bury the past Samco Sky News
well let's cross now to our political
correspondent Rob Powell who's standing
behind Westminster for us uh hello again
Rob I mean certainly that interim report
yesterday gave us an idea of the sort of
line of questioning that uh Boris
Johnson May face before the committee
later this month how do you think uh
it's looking for him I think it'll be a
bumpy encounter for him and at the
moment I think Boris Johnson is down but
probably not completely out I think the
most damaging parts of that report for
Boris Johnson were some of the WhatsApp
messages that were published from uh
some of his closest aides in which they
seem to be struggling to find
justifications for apparent rule
breaking I think what is not in there
though is a cast iron message or a cast
iron on paper proof that Boris Johnson
absolutely 100 knew what was going on
was against the rules but told the
commons completely the opposite and I
think as long as there is that glimmer
of doubt in there Boris Johnson will
continue to fight on in terms of why
this matters as Sam was suggesting in
his piece earlier this week week Boris
Johnson really began his latest Salvo
against Rishi sunax brexit deal I think
many MPS think that in the back of his
mind he would still like to be prime
minister again uh the danger I guess for
him is that this all flaring up again
reminds a lot of MPS why they got rid of
him in the first place
and Rob Moore uh WhatsApp Revelations uh
regarding Matt Hancock dominating the
front page of the telegraph today as
well yeah and centered on two topics I
think the first is about the events that
led to Matt Hancock's resignation as
health secretary the affair he was found
to be having with his close age
unicolored Angelo
um I don't think there's much in these
extensive WhatsApp messages from the
days after that story broke in the Sun
newspaper that really adds much in
material terms to what we know other
than that it is relatively late in the
day that Matt Hancock and his team start
contemplating basically fessing up and
saying that he'd done something wrong so
a kind of indication that politicians
often don't admit that they've done
something wrong until they absolutely
feel that they have to potentially
though the more newsworthy and more
interesting parts of the leaks published
by the telegraph this morning though is
around the tension between Matt Hancock
and Rishi sunak over lockdown
restrictions one part in particular
shows Matt Hancock warning the cabinet
secretary Simon case that they have had
lots of feedback that Rishi sunax e-take
to help out scheme was causing problems
in their intervention areas now of
course that was Rishi sunak's scheme to
try and help Hospitality he was out on
the airwaves defending it weeks after
Matt Hancock sent that message but
clearly the shows there was concern
right at the top of government that
actually some of Richie sunax schemes to
try and help the economy was having uh
problems in terms of the health impact
okay Rob uh for now thanks very much
well sticking with politics and that
investigation into partygate we can
speak further to the conservative MP
Paul Bristow who joins us live now a
very good morning to you thank you very
much indeed for joining us uh now that
interim report uh that we of course
heard yesterday found that Boris Johnson
may have misled Parliament several times
it doesn't look good for him does it
I think we need to remember
whose evidence that we're relying on
here this privilege is committed
on evidence now as has been proven by a
report from the chief of staff of the
leader of the opposition I mean this
this is just ludicrous I mean if it
wasn't so serious it would be laughable
relying on evidence from a report
compiled by the leader of the
opposition's chief of staff I mean I
just think this makes it makes a whole
process look utterly ludicrous
well see gray isn't yet uh the chief of
staff and in fact the committee did did
speak out and defended themselves
yesterday saying that you know they uh
the findings were not based on Sue
Gray's report and in fact that it
included a lot more evidence and many
more photos so you know you can't you
can't say that this is down to sue
Gray's report and in fact the committee
also complained that it was difficult to
get evidence from Boris Johnson or
suggest he was obstructive well hang on
a minute that's exactly what I'm telling
you and it's actually based upon their
own words themselves they say they rely
on Sue Gray's um a report in in the
report that they uh published so so
that's absolutely clear at the end of
the day we're trying this is a um a
report which one of the biggest seismic
political events of the past 12 months
they had an MP uh a prime minister that
was elected on a majority of 80 and we
ended up getting rid of them on the
basis of uh a few photos of a birthday
party which looks
to be honest it's not a very exciting
birthday party it makes us look utterly
ludicrous to the rest of the world and
quite frankly now it's I think it goes
against all natural Justice when we
realize that it's based on a report
produced by the leader of the opposition
Chief of Staff I think the whole thing's
ridiculous well you can say that but the
Privileges committee who produced this
interim report the majority of the MPS
on that committee were conservative and
the report includes one witness saying
that the then prime minister of course
Boris Johnson told a pact gathering at
number 10 in November 2020 that this is
probably the most unsocially distanced
gathering in the UK right now now you
you can't dispute what a what an
eyewitness has said can you oh of course
you kind of you see the picture of it a
packed Gathering I mean if this was
supposed to be a party it's probably one
of the worst parties I've ever seen in
my entire life I mean the whole thing
makes is a mockery of natural Justice
and makes us a laughing stock around the
world you know I'm in Bulgaria right now
and I'm remember going to an event in um
with some school children
yeah that we got rid of him because of a
few soggy sandwiches from Sainsbury's is
got a complete junk and again it's um
evidence that this is based upon a
report from the chief of uh staff to the
leader of the opposition it just looks
like a complete stitch up I mean I just
don't understand why anyone could think
any differently look you may say that
Boris Johnson you know is very popular
in Bulgaria I've spent a lot of time in
Ukraine they like him there too but it
doesn't mean that he's popular
domestically just because he's popular
internationally and certainly when you
say that you know you know just because
a few soggy sandwiches were dragged into
Downing Street that that doesn't feel
fair either when there are photographs
of Boris Johnson surrounded by lots of
bottles of alcohol just why is he
continuing to fight this is is he is he
still trying to make a political
comeback to be prime minister do you
think
I think he's continuing to fight this
because it's a perversion of natural
Justice
um the the idea I just keep saying to
you that this is based based on evidence
from a report compiled by the uh Chief
of Staff division of the opposition it's
just it's completely ludicrous I think
anyone who looks at this objectively
would reach the same conclusion and he
says surrounded by bottles and
everything if you look at these pictures
and you're trying to make out that this
is evidence of parties going on a
Downing Street he looks like the worst
part you've ever been to in my entire
life it's not a party anyone who looks
at the pictures Can can see for
themselves the whole thing is ridiculous
of course Boris Johnson could
potentially be sanctioned uh following
this uh Committee hearing
um do you think he could be suspended
from Parliament
well I think if that happened then we we
no longer live in a serious country I
mean we we've got
um you know
you could sit there and you can turn
around and say well you know this
happened X happened it's evidence of of
parties and Downing Street I think
anyone who empirically or or
independently looked at this evidence
would um would realize that that's
absolutely ridiculous Boris Johnson was
a Prime Minister elected by um the
overwhelming majority of the country 80
seat majority and um the way his
reputation has been besmirched the way
uh this has happened I think is evidence
of not a serious country and the fact
that is based upon as I say evidence
compiled by the leader of the
opposition's chief of staff I think goes
against all natural distance well she's
not the chief of staff yet and it's not
just a job it's not just Sue great it's
not just Sue gray who investigated is it
the Metropolitan Police also did and
they issued 126 fines so what do you say
to that
well they issued 126 fines that Boris
Johnson didn't get 126 fines to find
that Boris Johnson
we've got for the Soggy sandwiches and
the the slice of birthday cake that I
think if anyone as I say looked at uh
utterly uh objectively would think was
ridiculous uh and you know you I think
the inconsistency in the police's
approach especially when you look at
Arma and swigging beers in a curry in
Durham I think um well people can reach
their own conclusions can't they
what does the party need to do to move
on
well we have moved on we've got a new
prime minister and uh we're getting on
with the job what I'm here to talk to
talk to you about is um is Boris Johnson
and as I say I think um if we're going
to keep continuing continually going
down this line if we're going to
continually uh look to try and affect
the reputation of a man who was elected
on a um on a major mandate I I just
don't think we're a serious country
a lot of people are today saying that
his political future is in Peril he only
has a very slim majority in his West
London seat
how do you think the future looks for
Boris Johnson today
well Boris Johnson will make his own
decision about whether he wants to
continue to fight he he said he's going
to continue to fight we can sit there
and say we can look at his majority we
can look at my majority we can say well
that looks a pretty pretty um perilous
isn't it but look the people will decide
and I think uh that that's what's
important look Boris Johnson is a
colleague he's a member of the my
parliamentary party I hope that he
continues to do so and uh he's uh and
again he's I think his reputation it
absolutely needs to uh be defended he
was elected on a significant uh majority
and I'm sure he'll continue to make a
considerable impact on British political
life okay Paul Bristow it's been really
good to get your thoughts today have a
great weekend thanks so much for joining
us thank you
now 79 older people died every day in
England last year while waiting for
social care according to the latest
analysis from age UK the charity says
it's deeply concerned about the plight
of elderly people and is calling in the
chancellor to do more to help in the
budget later this month here's a look at
the latest figures
which show nearly 29 000 older people
died last year without receiving the
care they'd requested the charity says
this equates to more than 550 deaths a
week
or 79 deaths a day
well our correspondent Melena
veselinovich is here to discuss this
further 79 deaths a day is a staggering
figure and once again social care is in
the spotlight give us more context to
what this report is saying indeed so age
UK says that more than one in four
people in England wait more than six
months for that initial care assessment
that they ask for and that is just the
first step in getting their needs met
and the charity says that this has led
to around 2.6 million people aged 50 and
over in England basically not having any
help with things like going to the
bathroom having their food prepared for
them or help them feed themselves and
also washing themselves so staying at
home with their care needs unmet now
those who have family the charity says
or those family members step in as the
unpaid carers which is not an ideal
situation but they're particularly
worried they say about people living
alone and simply not having anyone to
help them and we do have a growing aging
population that has more complex needs
as opposed to something like 50 years
ago however the vacancies and the social
care sector are severe age UK says
there's 14 of unfilled posts at any time
and social care work is not very well
paid they want the chancellor to put
some money into it to entice more people
in the profession and try to cut down
those really long waiting lists because
they say even people with really
compelling cases have their needs unmet
and they end up waiting for a very long
time to have a very basic kind of decent
standard of living when they're at home
okay Milena thanks very much
now this hope of a pay deal being
settled for ambulance workers after two
unions suspended major strikes planned
for next week Unison and GMB will hold
talks with the government about a
payoffer for this year and next the
unite Union however will go ahead with
its ambulance industrial action on
Monday and Wednesday saying the
government has set on reasonable
preconditions for negotiations
and I will be speaking to Andy
Prendergast that's the GMB National
secretary at 8 40 this morning here on
Sky News stay with us for that
also making the news this morning three
lifeboats were deployed from Kent last
night after a ferry carrying almost 200
people caught fire in the channel it
started in the engine room on route from
Dover to Calais it's since been put out
and everyone on board is safe Irish
ferries has promised a full
investigation
police in Northern Ireland have been
given more time to question two men
arrested over the shooting of senior
detective John Caldwell
a Belfast Court granted an extension to
allow a 33 year old and a 57 year old to
remain in custody until Sunday detective
Caldwell remains in a critical but
stable condition after being shot
several times at a sports complex in Oma
last week
more violence and rioting have broken
out in Athens during the latest protest
in response to this week's deadly train
Collision almost 60 people are named
have been killed in Tuesday's crash
north of the capital which is blamed on
human error a railway official has been
charged with manslaughter
the White House physician says Joe Biden
will continue routine checks after
having a skin cancer treated last month
Kevin O'Connor says the common skin
cancer was completely removed from the
president's chest and he won't need any
more treatment for it the 80 year old's
health is under close scrutiny as he's
expected to run for a second term
now the oil which will be used to anoint
King Charles that his coronation has
been consecrated in Jerusalem it was
harvested from two Groves on the Mount
of Olives and is perfumed with Sesame
Rose Jasmine and other scents in a
formula dating back hundreds of years a
similar formulation was used for the
coronation of Charles late mother 70
years ago
now the Russian foreign minister Sergey
lavrov has provoked laughter and groans
from an audience by suggesting that his
country is the victim in the Ukraine war
the war which we are trying to stop and
which was launched against us using
Europe
Ukrainian people he was speaking at an
International Conference in India where
he earlier attended the G20 conference
in Delhi but it wasn't all mockery the
audience also applauded when Mr lavrov
was asked about the double standard of
western-led conflicts
the American actor Tom Sizemore best
known for his roles in Saving Private
Ryan and Black Hawk Down has died at the
age of 61. he suffered a brain aneurysm
on the 18th of February and died in his
sleep in hospital on Friday according to
his manager the actor struggled with
addiction during his career and was
jailed in the early noughties for
domestic violence
foreign
and it's time now for a quick look at
the weather
Warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
the mostly settled theme will continue
but it'll turn much colder next week I'm
afraid with some snow expected too and
for now it's a chilly start with patchy
Frost in the north and west Northeast
Scotland will see outbreaks of rain
through the morning parts of East Anglia
look damp too elsewhere it will be
mainly dry rather cloudy and a little
bit of sunshine if you're lucky
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
good morning you're watching Sky News
breakfast in the last few minutes we've
had an update on the ongoing fighting
around the town of back moot in Ukraine
from the ministry of Defense uh this is
what they've said the Ukrainian defense
of the donburst town of back moot is
under increasingly severe pressure with
intense fighting taking place in and
around the city regular Russian army and
Wagner group forces have made further
advances into the northern suburbs of
the city which is now a ukrainian-held
Salient vulnerable to Russia attacks on
three sides Ukraine is reinforcing the
area with elite units and within the
last 36 hours two key bridges in
backmoon have been destroyed including a
vital Bridge connecting the city to the
last main Supply route from back moot to
the city of chasivyar that update in the
last few moments for the ministry of
Defense regarding that town in the
Eastern region of the donbath uh the
back moot under increasing pressure will
bring more on that as we get it
now a brain tumor research has told Sky
News that the fight against the disease
should be treated with the same urgency
as the pandemic two Landmark reports
have revealed that child survival rates
have remained unchanged for decades and
some families are being forced to seek
medical options abroad his Sky
correspondent Sadia Chaudhary
if Louise could have bought anything in
the world it would have been more time
for her son
George had an aggressive cancer the
tumor in his brain was the size of a
golf ball
to treat it his parents raised nearly
half a million pounds but with limited
options for clinical trials in England
they had to spend it elsewhere we never
ever expected to be disadvantaged by
living in England we always thought we
had an amazing healthcare system which I
still believe we have but in the area of
brain tumors and brain tumor research
and advances in what's happened in
medicine in that area it's been
absolutely shocking there's an
explanation for that of 40 million
pounds allocated towards studying brain
tumors only 15 million has reached
researchers Charities say it should be
given the same urgency as the pandemic
the root of the vaccine there was a
spirit of innovation there was a golden
age of Life Sciences and we looked to
the scientists to provide the answer
we've got to make that look to the
scientists again in this area and
identify brain tumors as a critical
priority to achieve that there's an
all-party parliamentary group on brain
tumors it says the current system of
funding research is too complicated so
for example laboratory work isn't
connected with what's happening in
clinics and there's no database for
people to find out what sort of clinical
trials they may have access to and all
of that leaves brain tumor research way
behind that of other diseases like
leukemia and breast cancer the
government says it has invested in every
suitable application made but the appg
wants 110 million pounds ring fenced we
need to pull all of the work that is
going on to make sure that simple things
like tissue samples can be shared right
across the brain cancer research
community and more access to clinical
trials because when people have a
a brain tumor diagnosed and they know
the prospects are not very good they're
very very keen to take part in Trials
George died aged 13. his parents are
backing the appg's plans so that
families don't have to travel thousands
of miles when there's already a mountain
to climb
Saudia Chowdhury Sky News
now onto something a little bit
different this morning we're going to
lighten things up with a bit of music
have a listen and tell me what these
artists have in common
I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a few ear worms for you this
morning the Arctic Monkeys and Elton
John of course two have glastonbury's
main Headliners this year they're among
a star-studded lineup but questions have
been raised about a lack of female
Headliners well Helen brown is
Independence music critic and I'm
pleased to say joins us to discuss this
further good morning to you Helen thanks
so much thanks so much for joining us uh
what's your take on the representation
of women at Glastonbury this year it's
really disappointing
um you know and it's not just
Glastonbury so the top three Headliners
at Glastonbury or male you've got Isle
of white
um they've got four all-male Headliners
latitude three all male Headliners hats
off to download at Leeds and reading
they've got Billy eilish one out of four
and best of all also they've got Grace
Jones um he's there with Kooks and Craig
David but in a world where you know
there's 51 women that's pretty shocking
isn't it
yeah I mean we saw this it's not just
festivals is it we saw this at the Brit
Awards uh this year as well didn't we
um with them now merged into one best
artist category not one female uh
nominated what's the problem and I think
um Emily Evis the Glastonbury organizer
has put you know hit the nail on their
head here I think she's tried incredibly
hard to get female artists
um you know and they did I know they did
really want Taylor Swift um who had all
um all top 10 of the top 10 singles last
year with from her album midnights she's
a fantastic performer with a great back
catalog so it would have been absolutely
spectacular to see her unfortunately her
touring schedule clashed but Emily Evis
is right we have a problem with how we
support female artists on the way up now
one of the great artists one of the
great uh 48 of female artists who will
be appearing at Glastonbury is a
spectacular young performer called Rey
now she was signed to polydor six years
years ago during which time she says
they forced her to pump out pop hits
they she was a fantastic songwriter but
they kept giving her songs away to other
artists she became incredibly depressed
um and down-hearted she really felt
polydor didn't have her back she's now
put out her own her own album
independently my 21st century Bruce it's
an absolutely barnstorming album I
cannot understand why poly door weren't
backing her to put this music out under
her own name sooner why they weren't
getting her touring and I'm sure she
will be headlining one of these
festivals in a couple of years time but
it just goes to show that the record
labels aren't giving women the support
they need and they have to leave before
they will be able to say what Ray has
said that she hadn't had the sport she
said for six years I did what I was told
I kept my head down I didn't complain
because Young Musicians struggling to
make it really aren't making any money
at all so many of them have struggled
through the pandemic if they get a deal
they're just going to do what they're
tell at this point
yeah I mean there haven't been as many
major releases by female artists this
year and that inevitably will reflect in
the lineup at festivals but as you say
um glastonbury's organizer Emily Evis
has pointed to further down the pipeline
saying that actually it the issue is
with record labels not prioritizing
women why not what's the problem there
is what is it I I mean you know you'd
have to you'd have to put me in a in one
of those boardrooms so I could find out
what the problem is I mean even if you
look at the you know the top selling
um artists of 2022 it seems to be your
men and you think where is the problem
here because women are just as capable
of writing great Tunes performing great
Tunes we've got some but they often do
much more spectacular shows I mean one
of the women who I wish would be
headlining one of the festivals this
year would be pink who has a great pop
rock crossover appeal and with all of
her astonishing aerial gymnastics
um you know she puts on an absolutely
stormy show this this was a live act
that she did with this spectacular
trampoline artist
um I've met pink lots of times she has a
rocking raw voice she should have been
up there
um so yeah you know the problem is
supporting young women from the
beginning and then maybe by the time
some of them get to this stage you know
they don't want to do it but I I I'm
pretty sure they would I'm sure if you
dialed that pink you know I I know her
she is game on for anything she would
have loved this oh you know pink oh my
goodness she is amazing as she she
appears yeah she is she is the most fun
if you talk to anyone who's interviewed
her you will just see them coming out
giggling basically she's she's
everything she says she'll she'll sing
for you in an interview you know she'll
she because she's desperate to prove she
can do it she shouldn't have to be and
then we look at sort of some of the more
um some of the older women so someone
like Kate Bush could really have been
like headlining this year now I know
she's a notoriously shy performer she
did do that series of comeback gigs um
in London a few years ago and she had
that extraordinary Resurgence last year
um with you know running up that hill
all this stuff from stranger things
making her take off again with a whole
new generation she has got an
astonishing body of work she is you know
up there with you know she's a better
songwriter than Elton John
um you know she should be wow Bitcoin
yeah and I love Elton John
okay I'm sorry we're gonna have to leave
it there but it's been great to chat to
you and and I'm relying on you to get us
Pink singing live on break with us this
morning to review the papers is Alison
Stewart Allen chief executive of
international marketing partners and
Paul McNamee the UK editor of the big
issue good to see you both again and
there's lots to talk about this morning
certainly politics dominating the front
page of the front pages Alison you
picked out uh this article in the
guardian uh on the appointment of Sue
gray of course that's senior civil
servant who carried out the
investigation into partygate uh last
year now uh appointed as secure
starman's chief of staff
well uh you could say uh it's an
inspired Choice uh because of her track
record you know uh she uh firstly she's
a woman which is always a very good
thing to balance uh your uh cabinet and
your advisors uh but she's got a
fantastic track record you could say uh
in her approach to uh investigations uh
and I think
um you know while it's controversial uh
you know you could say that Mr starmer
has taken a risk uh in appointing her
and uh is hoping that pays off
yeah uh it's interesting isn't it Paul
just a thought from you on this story
which is a really big talking point
today in a lot of the newspapers and
with a lot of our political guests uh
you know Sue gray by all accounts almost
everyone you speak to talks about how
brilliant she is at her job and what a
great uh civil servant she is this is a
brilliant appointment by circus Dharma
to many but then the you know the
conservatives are using it to try and
discredit that investigation she did
last year what's your take on it all
they are and I heard your interview
earlier titling this and I and it is it
is a a motif that will keep coming at
the moment but I think that it's not
necessarily going to damage kirst armor
in the long run it is a useful way to
try and discredit any investigation into
Boris Johnson which suggests that he's
no agency of his own that he is not a
grown man he should be able to take
responsibility for his actions and if
he's not then it should never be prime
minister that's all different to be it
but in terms of Sue gray I think that
she has a smart appointment and I think
that the public probably still don't
trust Boris Johnson and that she is seen
as the person who was investigating with
good faith and let's not forget a lot of
senior Tories when Sue gray was doing
the investigation or crying from the
rooftops how good and Independence she
was I think of the public see that and
they can see that here starmer trusts
her now she is somebody to be trusted
and therefore so is he and of course the
timing of her appointment is clashing
with the interim uh report that we got
yesterday from the Privileges uh
committee uh Alison and that is
certainly dominating the papers today as
well uh double page spread inside uh the
mirror today with a with a new
photograph revealed by the committee of
Boris Johnson uh with members of his
team and bottles of alcohol on the table
uh during uh lockdown tell us more about
this
well I think these images just remind
the public of the fact that you know
while they were in lockdowns uh they
were denied being able to say goodbye uh
to their family members dying in
hospitals uh you have uh the leader of a
country uh having parties uh and I think
all this is doing is resurfacing uh
people's feelings of anger uh that they
did not have those movements with
families uh that they wished they'd had
they were not able to have their kids at
school uh learning properly instead they
were homeschooling uh and trying to
juggle homeschooling with the demands of
full-time work so I think this just
serves to maybe you know make people
angry again uh and actually it's
anchoring everybody in the past uh when
shouldn't we all be really focused
focusing instead on you know what what
good news is there uh you know covid I
guess because of the vaccine we ought to
really be celebrating the fact that
we're now able to go out we don't have
to wear masks we aren't socially
distancing uh anymore so
um yeah I I think it's really quite a
shame that uh this is uh back in the
back in the you know public eye uh when
really we ought to be looking at happier
times uh rather than you know reliving
the frustration of those moments I
should say Boris Johnson of course
maintains that there is nothing to
suggest in that in that report that he
knew that there was rule breaking taking
place and of course he will have a
chance to have his say before the
committee in a few weeks time let's move
away from politics now uh shall we Paul
you've pulled out this story in the
express which is
which is really interesting we've just
been talking about the lack of women
headlining at Glastonbury uh this year
and now this talking about the lack of
middle-aged women at work
yeah this is this is really interesting
we know that there is a a
um
work problem uh productivity problem uh
and a lot of people in the workforce and
this is something that only stores the
shadow equality secretary has drawn
attention to and that is 100 000 women
aged between 50 and 64 and some a little
younger as well I should say I withdrawn
from the labor market since covid for a
number of a number of reasons whether it
is because they they just say that they
wanted a change in life or they've got
more um they've got other
responsibilities at home or whatever it
is they they have withdrawn and it's a
problem because we need experience we
need women who know what they're doing
and have good lived experience in life
and lived experience noddering nodding
vigorously in approval there and so am I
Paul thanks so much Allison we're gonna
have to leave it there